هذا مثال على كيفية قيام الولايات المتحدة
مشاريع القوة العسكرية في منطقة
آسيا والمحيط الهادئ ، يو إس إس واسب ، إنها
سفينة تابعة للبحرية الأمريكية في بحر الفلبين ،
ويوضح الجيش كيف تعمل
الوديان والبحارة معًا بشكل وثيق
هنا أيضًا
خمسة وثلاثون
مداعبة لأعدائنا ، هذه القدرات الجديدة
تجعلنا ببساطة أكثر  قاتلة
ولدينا القدرة على جلب درجة أكبر من
الفتاكة للقتال والفوز في نهاية المطاف
في مسؤولي القتال في البنتاغون
أخبر CNN أن USS Wasp
ستشارك في التدريبات العسكرية المشتركة السنوية
التي أجريت في كوريا الجنوبية في أبريل
، وتشمل المناورات الحربية عشرات من  الآلاف
من القوات والبحارة من الولايات المتحدة وكوريا الجنوبية
في العام الماضي فقط ، شاركت الولايات المتحدة
في عروض كبيرة للقوة العسكرية
في المنطقة ردًا على
إطلاق كوريا الشمالية للصواريخ الباليستية
واختبارات الأسلحة النووية ، لكن ما
الفرق الذي يحدثه بضعة أشهر الآن بعد أن قال
الرئيس ترامب  إنه على استعداد
للقاء زعيم كوريا الشمالية وجهاً لوجه
لأن ما نراه هنا هو
دليل على أنه إذا كانت هذه التجربة  فشل الدبلوماسية الداخلية ،
وسيواصل الجيش
توفير خط
الدفاع الأول للولايات المتحدة وحلفائها في
المنطقة ، إيفان واتسون ، سي إن إن ، أوكيناوا.